you can have Rock top moments or Rock
Bottom moments I had a different
experience which is what I would
consider a rock top moment which is is
this all there is I had done everything
that I was supposed to do I was good at
school I was president of the fraternity
I was vice president of the powerlifting
team and vice president of the newspaper
I did the clubs I got the award I got
the prestigious job but then I just
looked at my life casted out to 30 years
and I was like I don't want to do this
so I was looking out at my condo that
was in a high-rise in downtown Baltimore
like looking over everything and I was
like very empty and that was when I
started thinking it was about a six
month window of time where every day I
would wake up and just not want to be
alive I was like this is uncomfortable
enough that I either should choose to
stop living or change how I live